بوتين:
أخبروهم بذلك وهذه شروطنا
وإن لم تعجبهم فحربنا إلى هذه اللحظة
لم تبدأ بعد!...
سلاح جديد تمنحه أمريكا لأوكرانيا
فما هو هذا السلاح يا ترى؟..
هل تذكرون أحداث ال١١ سبتمبر؟
هكذا يستمر زيلينسكي  باستعطاف
واسترحام الغرب والأمريكان
بينما يرد الروس بأن زيلينسكي كاذب كبير،
.. اليابان حليفة أمريكا تتعرض لقصف
مجهول وكيم جونغ أول المتهمين..
ما هي مطالب موسكو لإيقاف الحرب
وماذا تطلب كييف لتوافق على ذلك؟
مع موسكو، واشنطن، كييف لا حدود للتصريحات
والتهديدات ومطالب الرجاء،
فمنهم من يضع الشروط ومنهم من يطلق التهديد
تلو الآخر ومنهم من لا حول له ولا قوة
إلا بطلب العون والمساعدات،..
وبين موسكو وكييف الحرب السيبرانية
قد انطلقت فمن يوقفها؟
زيلينسكي:  الجيش الروسي تلقى خسائر
أكبر من خسائره في الشيشان وأفغانستان....
(لكن الكرملين يقول تختلف الأرقام في أرض الواقع
عما يتحدث زيلينسكي والغرب عنه،
وأرض المعركة هي من تتحدث
فلا داعي لكثرة التصريحات)
طالب الرئيس الأوكراني فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
أعضاء الكونغرس الأميركي بابتكار
أدوات جديدة للتصدي لموسكو
وفرض عقوبات جديدة لإيقاف الآلة الحربية الروسية.
وقال زيلينسكي إن بلاده تحتاج
إلى قرار أميركي لحماية سماء أوكرانيا،
وأضاف أنه إذا كان إنشاء منطقة حظر طيران
غيرَ ممكن، فإن بلاده تحتاج طائرات للدفاع
عن نفسها.
(الردود الأمريكية)
وفي أول ردود فعل أميركية بعد جلسة الكونغرس
بشأن تزويد أوكرانيا بأسلحة
لمواجهة سلاح الجو الروسي،
قال السيناتور الجمهوري جيم ريش إنه يتفق
مع الرئيس زيلينسكي بشأن توفير طائرات
وأنظمة الدفاع الجوي لأوكرانيا.
أما السيناتور الجمهوري ميت رومني
فدعا -بعد كلمة زيلينسكي للكونغرس-
إلى إيصال مقاتلات الميغ إلى أوكرانيا.
من جهته، قال مايك ماكول كبير الجمهوريين
بلجنة الشؤون الخارجية في مجلس النواب
إن أنظمة "إس-300" باتت موجودة في أوكرانيا.
في المقابل، قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
إن بلاده لن تتخلى عن حيادية أوكرانيا
ونزع سلاحها والقضاء على ما وصفها
بالنازية في كييف.
وأضاف بوتين أن الدول الغربية تزعزع
أسس النظام العالمي وأنها تدفع أوكرانيا
لمواصلة سفك الدماء من خلال تزويدها بالسلاح،
مؤكدا أن موسكو سترد على حزمة العقوبات الجديدة.
(أمريكا تمنح أوكرانيا سلاحا جديدا)
عرضت شركة "كلير فيو"
المتخصصة في تكنولوجيا التعرف على الوجوه
خدماتها على الحكومة الأوكرانية.
وتقول الشركة إن لديها قاعدة بيانات قابلة للبحث،
تضم صورا لـ10 مليارات وجه،
مصدرها الإنترنت.
وستفيد هذه الخدمة الأوكران
للتعرف على الروس في نقاط التفتيش
وعندما تنتشر حرب العصابات في المدن،
كما أنها مفيدة في التعرف على جثث القتلى،
ولكن الإحصائيات تقول أن القتلى
معظمهم من الجنود الأوكران..
(حلفاء أمريكا يتساقطون فهل تستطيع
الحفاظ على ما تبقى)
بعد أوكرانيا ها هي اليابان تعيش قلقا جديدا
حيث قالت طوكيو: أن كوريا الشمالية
تستمر بإطلاق الصواريخ والقذائف باتجاهها،،
فماذا لو قرر مجنون كوريا الشمالية
إطلاق المزيد من الصواريخ باتجاه اليابان
هل تستطيع أمريكا أن تمنع ذلك لتحافظ
على حليف استراتيجي قوي في آسيا؟
(حرب سيبرانية)
اختراق قناة أوكرانية وبث بيان خطير
بلسان زيلينسكي يقول (ألقوا السلاح)...
وفي الجانب الآخر: قراصنة يخترقون الموقع
الإلكتروني لوزارة الطوارئ الروسية.
(مطالب روسيا من أوكرانيا لإيقاف الحرب):
في البداية بدأ الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا
لتطهير القدرات العسكرية لكييف،
(وهنا يأتي طلب موسكو بإخراج جميع المدربين
الغربيين، والشحنات العسكرية والأسلحة
خارج أوكرانيا)
نزع النازية من السلطة الحاكمة،،
تثبيت وضع أوكرانيا في دستورها
وعلى المستوى الدولي، كدولة محايدة،
الاعتراف بشبه جزيرة القرم روسية،
الاعتراف بجمهوريتي دونيستك ولوغانسك
جمهوريتين مستقلتين..
بينما لدى كييف طلب واحد
وهو مغادرة القوات الروسية للأراضي الأوكرانية
دون قيد أو شرط،، وإنهاء العمليات العسكرية...
(بوتين يتحدث)
قال الزعيم الروسي أن: أوكرانيا
كانت تخطط لارتكاب مذبحة وتطهير عرقي،
وتابع بوتين أن الحكومة الأوكرانية
لم تكن تستعد للحرب والعدوان على روسيا
ودونباس فحسب بل بدأته.
وتابع: "كان بوسع النظام النازي في كييف
بدعم تقني من الخارج الحصول في المستقبل
المنظور على أسلحة دمار شامل،
وكانت روسيا هدفا له بطبيعة الحال".
(الأحداث والتطورات)
وزارة الدفاع الروسية، تعلن تدمير
٤٦ منشأة عسكرية أوكرانية خلال يوم واحد،
وأضافت الوزارة أنها أسقطت مروحيتين
أوكرانيتين و١٢ مسيرة خلال ٢٤ ساعة،
موسكو تنشر صورا لتدمير مخازن ومستودعات
عسكرية أوكرانية..
وزير الدفاع البريطاني:
أوكرانيا المحاصرة بحاجة لدعم حلف الناتو.
(زيلينسكي يستعطف الأمريكان)
تذكروا (11 سبتمبر 2001)
عندما حاول الشر تحويل مدنكم وأراضيكم
المستقلة إلى ساحات قتال.
بلدنا يشهد الأمر نفسه كل يوم».
وتوجه إلى الرئيس الأميركي قائلاً:
«أن تكون قائد العالم هو أن تكون قائد السلام».
بينما ترد موسكو بأن زيلينسكي
كاذب كبير يجيد الكذب مثلما كان
حين كان يمثل في السينما،
الخارجية الروسية:
قرار الاتحاد الأوروبي، تقديم دعم عسكري
تقني لأوكرانيا يتضمن أسلحة فتاكة،
لن يبقى دون رد
خيبة أمل: بايدن كان يأمل من بوتين
الالتزام بالقواعد الدولية..
جو بايدن يصف نظيره الروسي بوتين
بأنه مجرم حرب..
بايدن: سنوفر لأوكرانيا الأسلحة التي تمكنها
من الدفاع عن نفسها في الأوقات الصعبة المقبلة
محكمة العدل الدولية:
يجب على روسيا إيقاف العمليات العسكرية
في أوكرانيا. ويعتبر ذلك إجراء مؤقتًا،
لحين صدور الحكم النهائي في القضية،
والذي قد يستغرق سنينا عدة..
في ماريوبول جنوب شرقي البلاد،
قالت السلطات الأوكرانية إن قوات روسية
قصفت مسرحا في المدينة كان يستخدم
كملجأ للمدنيين.
أما الجانب الروسي فيؤكد ويكرر
عدم استهدافه للمدنيين،
لكن الذي يحصل في ماريوبول أن الأوكران
محاصرين لأسابيع تحت قصف روسي مكثف.
بوتين عن المختبرات البيولوجية الأمريكية
في أوكرانيا: "يحاولون الآن محو آثار
هذه البرامج السرية، لكن لدينا أرضية للترجيح
أن العمل جرى في أوكرانيا على مقربة
مباشرة من روسيا لإنتاج مكونات
الأسلحة البيولوجية
وتابع: "يبدو لنا أن الرعاة الغربيين
يدفعون سلطات كييف إلى مواصلة إراقة الدماء،
ويصدرون إليها شحنات جديدة من الأسلحة
ويزودونها بمعطيات استخباراتية
ويقدمون إليها أنواعا أخرى من الدعم،
منها إرسال مستشارين عسكريين ومرتزقة".
عمدة كييف: أكثر من نصف سكان العاصمة
الأوكرانية نزحوا عنها بسبب القصف.
الولايات المتحدة و4 دول أخرى
تدعوا إلى عقد اجتماع طارئ لمجلس الأمن
بشأن أوكرانيا
وزارة الخارجية الأميركية:
• نقود الجهود الدولية لعزل روسيا
بالتوازي مع تقوية موقف أوكرانيا التفاوضي.
• نعمل على تقديم ضمانات أمنية لدول شرق أوروبا.
مسؤولون أميركيون: الصين تساعد روسيا
مالياً وهناك مخاوف من رفع مستوى الدعم.
مستشار الرئيس الأوكراني:
مطالبنا واضحة وهي وقف إطلاق النار
وانسحاب القوات الروسية وضمانات أمنية.
ما نشرته فايننشال تايمز بشأن محادثاتنا
مع روسيا هو مسودة مطالب موسكو.
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية:
لن نسمح لروسيا باستغلال الاتفاق النووي
للهروب من العقوبات..
بدأت الحرب السيبرانية وزيلينسكي لا يتوقف
عن مطالبة الغرب بالدعم وروسيا ترد
التهديد بمثله وتتواصل العمليات العسكرية
في أوكرانيا، فهل هذه علامات
لإطالة الحرب إلى أجل غير مسمى؟